I'll tell it this story New York City
lawyer sobs in court as she sentenced to
15 months behind bars for firebombing
NYPD van with Molotov cocktail fashioned
out of a Bud Light bottle during BLM
protests urugu Rahman asked the judge to
spare her prison time and give her a
second chance to redeem herself for what
she called a momentary lapse of judgment
yo lady
prison is for dangerous people okay 15
months you're getting a slap on the
wrist considering you you you fire
bombed a car if it was like she threw a
rock and it hit somebody in the head I
might be like okay you know 15 months
don't throw rocks people come on no she
threw a fire bomb she like was handing
them out to people so uh you know again
speaking of low IQs we're already seeing
uh we're already seeing how bad it can
be when these people have momentary
lapses of judgment the scary thing about
it is that people like like her they
think they're smart that's the scary
thing a midwitism
you know like midwoods are slightly
above average but they're very convinced
that they're usually part of when people
get called midwits it's that they are
also part of that convinced that they
are very intelligent which makes it
dangerous midwit is basically they are a
little smart like a little bit above
average but but they're not smart enough
to truly understand so they're active
players like these journalists the the
corporate press they're midwits
you know there's that IQ bell curve you
see all the time where the dumb guy and
the smart guy agree on things and the
average person is like doing the wrong
thing pro-establishment or whatever
this is kind of scary when you when when
you think about it and then you realize
that we're going to have a wave of
substantially stupider people due to the
masking policies and the lockdown
policies in these schools these kids are
all developmentally stunted and they're
not getting they're not getting those
years back I don't know if you guys ever
read about the the girl Raised by Wolves
I mean not the girl but there's a bunch
of stories of like kids they never learn
you know by the time they're adults
there was like some story I read about a
woman who was uh like seriously abused
and locked in a basement until she was
13. it was like Trixie or something like
that when she was when she was finally
rescued she couldn't learn to speak
proper colloquial English she could only
say certain words like hungry sleep but
she couldn't actually articulate long
Thoughts with other people that's scary
man those uh foundational developmental
years are really really important
um for children to become adults or to
be able to function whatsoever in
society so yeah a child can survive in
the woods being raised by wolves you can
survive but you can't you're going to
have so many developmental issues so
with these children who have grown up
never seen their parents face or very
rarely seen their parents face which is
a huge part of it of forming the
connection between mother and child and
father and child they don't have any of
that so that does explain partially why
the IQ deficit is what we're seeing in
the preliminary data you ever see that
study where they had the mom they
brought in a bunch of moms with kids and
then the mom would not respond to the
baby's facial cues have you seen that
it's so sad the baby like tries to get
the mom to react and they like they told
the mother just remain stone-faced and
do not respond to the baby and then a
veg the baby starts crying like freaking
out yeah these immune system deniers are
absolutely sick and disgusting I'm
serious when we look at the policies
that they've implemented they knew the
horrors that this was going to bring and
we've seen video after video of these
fat bureaucratic totalitarian teachers
just shove a mask on a child's face as
they're literally fighting with them
toddler small children in kindergarten
were forced to be masked which is
leading to severe
development developmental issues that
we're going to be seeing the long-term
consequences of especially in the future
there was even major politicians that
came out and said I guys I made a
mistake you did of course you did we all
knew you you did we were talking about
this we were warning about this and our
voices were censored by big Tech social
media and this is why it went on for so
long it was because of that censorship
it's because people couldn't push back
it's because the ideas couldn't be
challenged or tested in the public
sphere and we were censored and we had
to continue with this ludicrous nonsense
bullcrap insane policy that has hurt
children in so many unspeakable ways I
interviewed to Mom on Long Island a
couple months ago when schools were
going back and forth over whether or not
they would remove their mask policy and
she's just telling me about her
experience I wrote about it for the site
but one of the worst parts of it she
told me was that there was a girl in the
school who got sick in class threw up in
her mask she's like in the second grade
and they made her walk to the nurse
office without taking her mask off evil
like evil this is insane why would we
live this way well even before this did
you ever hear the story about what's
going on in Chicago where they they lock
kids in padded rooms
there was a little boy who was like
acting out so they brought him into a
padded room locked the door and then
just left him there for hours he started
screaming he had to go to the bathroom
so they ignored him and when his parents
finally came they found him like with
crap on his pants and he's like a little
kid like like after I hold he's like
five or six or something
so this stuff's been going on it's only
getting worse homeschool your kids
because uh one last point on the covet
stuff there was a study that I came
across it's um by Dr Raymond Palmer it's
called covid-19 vaccines and the
misinterpretation of perceived side
effects Clarity on the safety of
vaccines if you don't mind I'd like to
read a few lines what is what is the
what is uh with the basic premise is
that all of the side effects are just
because people were mean about it people
were mean on Twitter about about whether
or not they wanted to get vaccinated
they did a study that's it's not a real
study it's his contention
his contention is publication it's it's
published in um the Journal of
biomedicine in uh just last year is that
a reputable yes it is that's the
horrifying part
basically his much of this
anti-vaccination sentiment could be
attributed to the alleged side effects
that are perpetuated across social media
from anti-vaccination groups
fear-mongering and misinformation being
peddled by people with no scientific
training to terrorize people into
staying unvaccinated could be causing
the side effects in the vaccination
process
we're not talking about like kids being
masked we're talking about it's in any
kind of side this I just came up I saw
this today but any kind of side effect
of everything anything socially because
people are medically is because of
anti-vaxxers being mean on social media
well hold on there
guys we gotta stop being mean I know
that's the only way is that The Cure
well that's the you know everybody will
be healthier well to be fair I mean
stress does cause health problems it
does that's his contention I think his
contention is garbage well we can all
try to be a little nicer also like I
don't feel like the anti-vaxxers were
again
Twitter user but I felt like the
dominant pressure was to get vaccinated
was to follow through and those who
questioned that were the ones who were
attacked he's literally accusing people
of what the establishment was doing yes
and by as a perfect example perfectly
described it except for his side was
doing that right and what his contention
was his his evidence for it later and it
is that well women uh had more uh
myocarditis and different kinds of
cardiac events following
um you know exposure to social media and
it's because of that that there's this
this issue
it is plausible women are more likely to
have really severe stress reactions too
well social pressure
we talked about that study where like
teenage girls are getting depressed from
Instagram
I mean if if if if you are susceptible
for whatever reason be it covid or now
they like now they have that that study
that NBC News reported about where
they're doing Pfizer and modern I think
are doing long-term studies on on
myocarditis and pericarditis uh which
they say is very rare but my point is if
you are susceptible for whatever reason
and you're having heart palpitations
because of stress on social media
I mean I don't think anti-vaxxer makes
the most sense but the idea that social
media stress could make put you like put
increase your risk for any kind of uh
issue yeah just kind of a weird
convenient thing to to say no I think
we're seeing this increased stress in
people and it is causing them cardiac
issues it must be the anti-vaxxers on
social media that are responsible for it
which is again a convenient way to um
you could say it's cancel culture oh
sure the fear of being canceled of not
fitting in of not virtue signaling is
causing people to have heart problems I
actually would believe that too
especially with what we know I think you
know we've seen a lot of uh young girls
negatively impacted by social media they
get depressed they don't get enough
likes but they're younger so they're not
their hearts aren't going to give up but
what if you're like a 50 60 year old
woman and you're you're wrapped up in
the stuff like I don't know if you guys
saw the Rosie O'Donnell Kathy Griffin
Tick Tock they put out and it's just
cringe like super cringe but I imagine
for them they're a lot older they're
active on social media they're probably
getting stressed out bad by the stuff
but they also just have old Hearts so
like I wouldn't be surprised if you came
to me and said that Kathy Griffin was
having a heart condition I'd be like
yeah the lady's strung out on Twitter
like she's losing it sure with a problem
with a study like that where he's making
his contention and his conclusion is
that well there's competing variables
here there's an alternative hypotheses
and you're just contending that this
must be the correct yeah yeah but that
one could very well be part of it as
well is that women really are getting
more stressed out because of social
pressures on on social media I think
it's fair to say that you know
myocarditis is not caused by Mean Tweets
I think I think I think that's the
Baseline that we should be having here
but hold on prove it prove it in a study
and then I'll I'll rely on Pfizer and
moderna to tell us what to believe in
since well they're investigating
themselves so they're very trustworthy
right but I do think it's a fair point
to say if you're susceptible
he's being stressed out will like will
increase your risk probably like
cortisol stressors causes negative
Health consequences the point I'm trying
to bring up is guys I get it but social
media is is bad for us the algorithms
are manipulating us they're controlling
us into believing stupid political
nonsense and young girls are getting
depressed mostly young guys are getting
depressed too but it's mostly young
girls getting depressed by this I got no
problem being like I am absolutely
willing to throw the algorithms of
Facebook under the bus on this one if it
means we can I don't know do something
about it change it or fix it well there
are a couple uh wrongful death lawsuits
going there's one in the UK with like a
12 year old boy there's one in
California with like a 19 year old girl
who are uh they they basically are
arguing that the algorithms fed them
content that they may have been
predisposed to anxiety or issues but it
encouraged these mental health issues to
the point where at least one of the one
of the children killed themselves if
it's the 12 year old boy in the UK that
I'm thinking of then that lawsuit is is
completely bogus yeah because yes he was
being bullied online but he had horrible
home life and then it also turned out
that if that's the one I'm thinking of
that his mother then he had been he was
brain dead and was kept in line on
ventilators for three months while he
was literally his brainstem was
necrotizing while she was making money
by posting pictures of him on social
media in a diaper and if that's the same
story then I don't know I know there
have been several lawsuits I just find
it interesting and again maybe not all
of them are valid but I find it
interesting that people are choosing
this route to say like we are
experiencing the suffering right away we
didn't evolve in this in these
conditions whatsoever so of course it's
it's overstimulating to the the
diplominergic center of the brain thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time